c'est ici à l'aérodrome de toussus le
noble que se trouve l'avion alpha
électro ce biplace à motorisation
électrique est présenté aujourd'hui dans
le cadre des journées parlementaires du
groupe modem
le premier ministre edouard philippe est
également présent le président de mon
groupe patrick mignola m'a demandé de
réfléchir à valoriser deux initiatives
l'une sur la tranquillité publique et
l'autre sur la manière dont on peut sur
les territoires faire évoluer la
transition écologique depuis quelques
mois l'aérodrome de toussus a mis en
place une expérimentation de réduction
des nuisances sonores
parallèlement il accueille l'alpha
électro avion entièrement électrique
dotée d'une autonomie de 140 km et qui
ne génère aucune émission de co2 c'est
une cire construction formidable attrait
très intéressante du point de vue de
l'aéronautique au d'état
toussus-le-noble du point de vue des
ingénieurs du point de vue de la
recherche du point de vue des grandes
écoles et comme vous savez j'ai été miné
de l'éducation de la recherche donc pour
moi c'est très important pour les cars
entiers députés présents ces journées
sont l'occasion de se pencher sur les
sujets de l'automne il est également de
tradition que le premier ministre vienne
rencontrer les parlementaires de la
majorité
c'est bien qu'ils soient fidèles à ce
rendez vous et ça montre aussi l'intérêt
d'avoir un pluralisme au sein de la
majorité le groupe lois de la république
en grande marche le groupe modem qui se
qui se complète d'une certaine façon
avec chacun leur histoire
un déjeuner a clôturé ces deux journées
de travaux déjeuner durant lequel le
premier ministre edouard philippe a
souligné la bonne entente qui régnait au
sein du groupe parlementaire modem